- Next up, though, is a live interview
with researchers working on conversational agents,
one of the areas
in which Microsoft
Research is a pioneer.
I'm having a conversation today
with Lucy Vanderwende.
I hopefully said that right.
- You did.
- Bill Dolan of Microsoft and,
of course, Alan Ritter of The Ohio State.
I added the "the" in there for you, Alan.
- Thank you.
- Assistant professor from
The Ohio State University.
They are going to talk to us today
about, well, talking.
They did a lot of research
in conversational systems.
Welcome, Lucy, Bill, and Alan.
How you doing?
- Great.
- Doing well, thank you.
- Fantastic.
So, what are some of the interesting things
happening in conversational agents?
Anybody can take that one.
- Well, in the past in NLP,
what we used to do is build models
that really involved a lot of hand
coding to try to decide
how to respond to a given input.
And in the last several years,
the field has been overtaken
by newer data-driven techniques
that allow us to train models on huge volumes
of naturally occurring data,
specifically from social media,
where we can find-
For the first time
we can really get access
to enormous volumes
of text involving people
having a back-and-forth conversation.
- I remember the first conversational agent
I ever wrote was the typical ELIZA, you know?
This isn't that anymore, right?
What's the difference between ELIZA and the stuff
that we're working on here?
Why don't you take that, Alan?
- Yeah, so I think ELIZA
is doing something pretty interesting,
but how it's actually
built is really simple.
It's just a very small set of regular
expressions or handwritten rules,
where as here we're
really trying to learn
how to build conversational agents
just from lots of data.
So, learning them using techniques
from statistical machine translation, for example.
- OK, so statistical machine translation
was something that I got to work on a little bit.
I'm not understanding the link
between machine translation and a conversational agent.
Why don't you take that one?
- Think of it as there's the language
of the person who's doing the speaking
and the language of the person
who's doing the hearing.
So, for example, you say,
"I'm going to Las Vegas tonight."
I'm going to say, "Have a nice flight," right?
It's a kind of a translation.
You say one thing, and I'm quite conditioned
to say one of a couple of things,
or you know, "What are you going to do there?"
So, it's kind of an input
and an output.
The difference between conversation
and machine translation
is that in machine
translation the content
is all given to you,
and you just have to faithfully
do the translation.
With conversation generation,
you're also kind of deciding what to talk about.
That's a bit
of a difference, right?
There's some content
selection going on there.
- When I'm thinking of machine learning,
I'm thinking of there's a target output,
or I'm looking for a specific task
that I'm solving.
When I talk about conversation
in generalities,
I'm having a hard time
nailing down the task.
And when I can't do that,
the computer has a hard time.
So, Bill, what's the task?
-No, that's the- I mean, your background
in machine translation shows,
because that is exactly
one of the challenges
that we faced with this work.
As Lucy was saying, in translation,
the semantics of the input defines
the semantics of the output.
You're trying to affect the form,
but the semantics needs to remain
constant across that transition.
In this conversational space,
you're right, it's a wide-open field, potentially.
You can respond in any way
to what I might say to you.
But we are taking advantage
of the fact that, as Lucy was saying,
there's a huge amount
of predictability in our responses,
not so much in what we say
but how we say it.
So, for example, if you ask me
a yes or no question,
there's a lot that's going
to be predictable
about the form
of that response.
- Sure.
- As Lucy was saying,
there's a lot of sort of polite conversation,
chit-chat, back and forth
that is highly predictable.
As Lucy was saying, if I say
I'm going to the airport, you're likely to say,
"Have a nice flight,"
or "Where are you going?"
or "Are you going on vacation?"
Something like that.
And what we have done...
In translation, there's a metric
that has been very powerful in helping decide
whether a change you've made
to the algorithm
was good or not, BLEU,
which is an automated metric
[ indistinct ].
And we've adapted BLEU in this conversational space
to allow ourselves to, in an automated way,
decide probably
whether that change
we just made to the algorithm
was good or not.
- And you said it's called BLEU?
- BLEU in translation is the algorithm- I'm sorry,
is the evaluation metric.
- So, maybe I'm a little old or I didn't remember BLEU,
but can you talk a little bit
about what that metric is
and how it actually applies?
Because again, I'm having a hard time.
I know you mentioned it.
I'm having a hard time matching the two.
Why don't you take that?
- Sure, sure, yes.
So, BLEU is like an automatic evaluation metric.
One way you could evaluate translations
is to have people look
at a translation,
like an expert translator,
and say is this
a good translation, right?
Whereas BLEU will actually compare
the translation against a reference translation
and try to determine
whether it's correct,
because there's a lot of different ways
you could translate a sentence.
- By reference, that means
a human-generated translation.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And by the time you take a sentence
in English and translate it 10 times into Japanese --
10 different people translate
that into Japanese --
you've begun to cover the space of plausible
translation into Japanese.
- Exactly.
- And now, you can look
for n-gram overlaps,
so those word sequence overlaps between
the way your system translates
that input sentence
and the way humans did.
And we've done something very similar
in this conversational space,
looking again on social media
for inputs that have,
across this huge body
of text of data,
many different responses
produced by many different people,
so we can do something
very similar.
Given this input, we predict
the response is this.
Now, compare sequences of words
in that predicted response
to what we found
across the corpus
for what people
actually said
when "I'm going to the airport"
was uttered as the input.
And so, again, the space
of possible responses is infinite,
but you can begin to cover it
in this way if you have enough data.
- Yeah, I think in conversation,
the space of outputs
is much larger
than translation, right?
So, in translation, the input and output
are semantically equivalent,
so it's kind of a more
constrained problem than conversation.
- But it's not
totally infinite, right?
Because conversation, successful conversation,
runs along their cooperative principles,
and I'm not going
to be redundant.
So, if you ask me a question...
Like, ELIZA pretty much worked
because ELIZA asked the question
you are compelled
to answer, right?
So, you are getting tricked into- not tricked,
but- - Falling into the rut.
- But you fall into the rut.
That's what we as cooperative people
in a conversation do.
And so, to be cooperative also when you ask me a-
If you say something, I'm not going to say,
"Oh, yeah, my hair pin is blue,"
because it's a total non sequitur.
So, the space of things that are relevant
to say in a conversation is not infinite.
It's not deterministic.
I can say a couple of things.
I have some flexibility, but I'm not going to totally
go off the rails, either.
And that's what we do as people.
When you say something, you kind of predict
what I might say, what I might start talking about.
But the thing that makes it interesting is
when we slightly veer off-topic,
when I introduce a new theme,
and that makes conversation engaging.
- Again, my challenge that I'm having
is when I'm doing translation,
there is a specific output.
And you mentioned nine
reference translations, right?
But when we're looking
at conversational topics...
Like, I've had my four-year-old
come out of left field and say something.
- Yeah, I mean, let me just interrupt,
because I completely agree
with everything you're saying,
and I also did not know this
approach was going to work.
But Michel Galley, who's in our research group,
is a machine translation person.
He was completely convinced that this same kind
of automated metric would work in this space.
And to my surprise, it does,
because so much of the response is predictable,
even if the specific
content is not.
If you say, "Are you going?" the response
is very likely to be "Yes, I am,"
"No, I'm not," something or other.
And just that "Yes, I am," "No, I'm not" is enough
to give us some signal as to
whether we're probably
doing something reasonable
with this algorithm or not.
And it's really critical to have
an automated metric like this,
because it's the combination --
I would say;
maybe you want to correct me
if you disagree, but...
I think translation really began
to leap forward in quality...
- Oh, no question.
- ...when you got the confluence
of a lot of data,
parallel data,
that automated metric,
and better machines.
I think that troika allowed the field
to leap forward, because without that automated metric,
BLEU, in the old days,
you had to wait for people
to manually score your translations.
It would take a lot of money
and a lot of time to decide
whether that tweak you made
yesterday was a good thing.
But once you could hit a button and get an instant read
on whether you made probably an improvement or not,
things really began to accelerate.
And in this conversational space,
again, that evaluation,
finding an automated
evaluation metric,
is a critical component
to really making progress
in this machine learning area.
- So, when I started machine translation,
we did this thing called a noisy channel model.
Is it the same thing?
Because I don't know what state of the art
is in machine translation anymore.
- Yeah, so when we first started doing this,
when I was first doing an internship at
MSR- - So, you were actually
at Microsoft as an intern?
- Yes.
- That's awesome.
- Yeah, it's awesome.
- Tell us about that.
- This was, like, 2010,
and this was really the first attempt in the field
to build a data-driven dialog-
- That's exactly
when I finished grad school.
No, actually, I was in till 2012,
so that was right around the time that I was...
- Yeah, what Alan did was really the first attempt
to take parallel data in the form of input-response
and learn a translation
model from it
that's going to predict
[ indistinct ].
- So, tell us more about that.
- Yeah, so I mean, I think I was just really
in the right place at the right time.
I think Microsoft Research was one of the first places
really investing a lot of effort
in this data-driven conversation thing.
And yeah, when we first started out,
we were using these noisy channel type models.
But recently, the neural network translation models
have become more popular for both machine translation
and in conversations.
- Is that because the deep learning models
are better at taking a lot of input, or...?
I'm trying to understand, because like I said,
right at 2010, you remember,
that's when everyone was like,
"Oh, neural networks don't work."
And then, all of a sudden,
they really did,
because of the depth and...
- It's actually interesting.
I think the models that Alan built
tended to produce more
interesting responses,
but they weren't very fluent.
And with the advent of neural models,
that same data dumped into the neural models produces-
- So, this was smoothing.
- Yeah, exactly, very fluent
responses that tend to be bland.
The model tends to produce this
very dull, statistically safe response.
The big challenge has been to try to goad it
into saying something more interesting.
- Do like a Boltzmann sum, push it out of its state.
- But it might also be that it's helping us
to differentiate how we talk from what we say, right?
So, there's two axes.
It's how we say things -- is it English, is it French?
-- and what is it that we're saying.
We're saying the same thing
in these various languages.
And so, the neural models are really good
at learning how we say things,
and we're now working towards
improving our ability
to control what it says.
- So, I mean, it feels like you're trying
to inject some kind of personality into it somehow.
Is that...?
- Right, there's personality,
there's grounding...
So, Bill's previous example was always,
"Is the Starbucks open?"
Well, that depends
on where you are.
Are we in Seattle?
What time is it?
- Oh, I see.
- The answer needs to be grounded, right?
So, that's the what it's going to say.
How it's going to say that -- "Yes, it is,"
or "Hey, there's only 10 minutes
left when it's open" --
that's the how we're saying things.
- And it's worth saying that I think this grounding
is critically important, as Lucy was saying,
that it's really vital that we connect
these conversations to the world,
or it's just blather.
I think traditionally in natural language processing,
we tended to map from language into language
whether it was translation
or summarization
or spelling, grammar correction,
and that kind of thing.
- But I think, even this, there are some sort
of useful applications, like if I get a text message.
If my friend says, "I'm feeling sick," you can maybe
predict how to respond to them
without even seeing any input
that they're typing in,
sort of then click confirm
and send to respond.
- I feel like we've talked about this a lot,
and I want to see something now,
and I want you to talk to it, Bill.
Looks like you've got some
on your computer here.
Let's see.
He's put his glasses down.
It's going to be good.
- Yeah, let me just try an example.
Well, we can do the one that Lucy...
Sorry.
Something kind of frequent,
like "I'm feeling really sick."
- I'm feeling really sick today.
OK.
- Which is really common, you know.
You're going to see that...
Sorry, this is a little slow
over the network, I think.
Here we go.
Again, this is not being retrieved
from a corpus of responses.
This is being made up by
the neural model, word by word.
This is a very high-frequency kind of exchange.
Oops.
- And that's cool, because usually
when I'm doing stuff with machine learning,
there's a specific task.
But you just literally typed in
"I'm feeling sick today,"
and to me, that's not input that
I would give a computer, right?
But it's cool that you've been able
to actually model
the typical responses
for that kind of thing.
Can you show us some more examples?
- Yeah, so why don't I just
show you something that...
Let's see, something like,
"My mother is coming to visit."
Actually, I'm going to do-
I'm going to restart the context,
so it's not affected by the prior term.
- So, when you say it's not affected,
does it keep like a stack of information?
- Yeah, in various experiments, we're taking advantage
of prior context to influence what's said.
I really just want to point out the pronoun here,
that it's getting "she."
First of all, it's a well formed sentence,
and the pronoun is right.
If I said something like, "My father is..."
Well, let's try that over here.
My father is coming to visit.
- So, there's a deep model...
- He.
- I'm sorry?
- So, you see "he,"
which again is very low-level
kind of experience to show.
But it is really fascinating to me
that it's getting the words right,
it's doing the lexical choice very nicely,
it's getting the word order right,
it's getting the pronoun right,
and it's very good at this kind of pattern.
- I mean, indirect object pronouns,
when I was doing research,
was the bane of NLP's existence, right?
- Right, and you would have imagined that
you'd have to write a rule, right?
- Yeah.
- You would imagine that we needed
to do coreference resolution and all of that,
but it's just falling out
from the model.
Because the models, because they've been
trained on such huge amounts of data,
they've learned how to talk.
- I see.
So, what can this be used for?
Because right now, to me...
If someone's watching this that
doesn't know about NLP and hasn't done research in this
and is not completely blown away --
because I am -- what would this be used for?
- Yeah, do you want to...?
- I think, like I sort of mentioned before,
like if you want to
automatically generate replies
to an email or a text message
you could sort of just- you know,
it could generate something and just click send
if it's a common response.
I think there's also a lot of opportunity to integrate
this into more goal-directed dialog systems,
so it's more like natural.
Instead of feeling like really talking to your phone,
it's more like you're talking to a person
and having a natural conversation.
- I see.
Bill?
- No, I was going to say
that I think this notion of grounding
is really important,
and that's where the leap to neural models
from the older statistical models
is really important.
Because in these neural models
where everything's a vector,
we can entangle
linguistic information
with real-world information.
Features from a photo,
something else in your environment,
the state of your machine,
all of that kind of thing
can be entangled
in this model
that now knows something
about both language
and its intersection
with your program state.
So, we can begin to now move away
from this kind of chit-chat scenario.
We're really not trying
to build a chit-chat model here.
As Alan was saying, we're trying to build
a model that is aware of your world around you,
but also knows
how to engage you
in a turn-taking conversation.
And its responses can be influenced, and potentially
your responses can influence the state of the world.
- Is there a way- I'm sorry, go ahead.
- I was just going to say, again,
if you follow the cooperative
principle of conversations,
you don't want a computer
that robotically says,
"I am talking
at this moment at..."
We leave out a lot
of information as well,
because maybe you've already
told me that information.
So, we also want it to-
the how needs to be natural.
The more natural we can get
the conversational agent to be,
the more you're willing
to interact with it
and to share with
a conversational agent information
about you that will help it
do its task later on.
- I think we're coming at this
from this perspective that we're not trying
to build either
a chit-chat engine
or a purely transactional,
task-oriented dialog engine.
We're trying to blend both
into the same model.
- So, you're saying you can take this
conversational model and blend it with,
for example, your insurance
company bot.
And what it will do is you can start
talking insurance to it,
and so you get the model
for insurance knowledge
with this sort of smoothing
model that's smoothing
the real conversation.
- Yeah, if you think about renting
a car at an airport,
most of that conversation
may be transactional,
but there's likely to be some
sort of polite sugar in there.
The person behind the counter will say,
"Oh, you're going to the Grand Canyon?
The weather's beautiful out there today."
Something like that.
It's relevant to the conversation,
but it's not relevant to deciding what car
you're going to get or how many days
you're going to have it.
So, we're aiming more
for that combined model.
- Well, this has been really awesome.
Apparently, we ran out of time.
This is good stuff.
I mean, it touches to the heart of some of the stuff
that I got to work on.
This is really impressive work.
Thanks so much for spending
some time with us.
Thank you, Bill and Lucy, for your time
and fascinating discussion.
We look forward to hearing more about
conversational agents in the future.
Also, not forgetting the professor.